Eu quero iniciar concluindo a discussão
que começamos na última aula
sobre os modos de pensar
sobre a hesitação levantada
pelo caso do Trolley.
Vocês se lembram que a hesitação
é que existe uma aparente
assimetria em nossas respostas
para o caso da testemunha e o
caso do homem gordo,
embora ambos envolvam matar
1 para salvar 5.
E vimos, na última classe, a
resposta de Judy Thomson,
que diz: não há
assimetria nos 2 casos,
porque quando refletimos sobre o
caso hipotético adicional
em que há uma 3ª via onde
está você, reconhecemos
que não é moralmente aceitável
desviar o trem na testemunha,
da mesma forma que não é
moralmente aceitável
empurrar o homem gordo.
No outro extremo, vimos a
resposta de Josh Greene,
que diz: assim como é
moralmente aceitável
desviar o trem na testemunha,
é moralmente aceitável
empurrar o homem gordo.
E na medida em que encontramos
diferentes respostas, diz Greene,
isso se deve ao fato de que a parte
emocional do nosso mecanismo
de resposta do cérebro é ativado pela
natureza pessoal da proximidade
no caso do homem gordo e,
como resultado,
damos uma resposta que, para ele, é
moralmente injustificada.
E no final da última aula começamos a
refletir sobre uma 3ª possibilidade,
que está em algum lugar
entre Thomson e Greene,
embora mais perto de Greene.
E se trata do argumento de
Cass Sunstein de que,
apesar das respostas diferirem
– e talvez diferirem em aspectos
impossíveis de serem mudados –,
no fundo, os casos são iguais.
E, embora não tão
determinado como Josh Greene,
ele está inclinado a pensar que
se queremos que os casos
sejam visto iguais, o que devemos
fazer é empurrar o homem gordo.
Vocês se lembram que o argumento dele
procede da seguinte maneira:
Ele sugeriu que é incontestável
utilizar as heurísticas
nos casos não-morais, e que essas
heurísticas, embora úteis,
muitas vezes nos conduzem a erros;
e então ele destacou que, assim como
isso ocorre nos casos não-morais,
também ocorre nos casos morais.
E fomos embora da última
classe pensando
sobre o argumento de Sunstein
de que nos casos morais
as pessoas costumam usar
as heurísticas.
Vocês se lembram que ele deu
alguns exemplos do trabalho
de Jonathan Haidt de situações em
que as pessoas expressavam
desaprovação moral para ações
para as quais elas não podiam
encontrar justificativa.
O incesto consensual entre os irmãos,
limpar o chão do banheiro com
a bandeira do país...
As pessoas estavam inclinadas a ver isso
moralmente problemático mesmo quando,
ao serem questionadas,
não conseguiam dizer qual a regra
moral que essas coisas violam.
E o que Sunstein afirma no
artigo é que, em geral,
podemos analisar a literatura das
heurísticas e vieses e ver,
instância após instância, que o
enquadramento de um caso
afeta a nossa resposta
tanto nos casos não-morais
quanto nos casos morais.
Vocês se lembram que na 3ª aula,
justo quando aprendíamos a
usar os clickers,
eu disse que o usaríamos nesta aula...
portanto, é hora de cumprir a promessa.
Quando estávamos aprendendo a usá-los
fomos apresentados ao caso da
doença asiática,
que é o seguinte:
Uma doença terrível atingiu 600
pessoas na sua cidade, certo?
Portanto, há 600 pessoas na cidade
que estão destinadas a morrer.
Você é o prefeito e estão
disponíveis 2 opções de tratamento:
o plano A ou B.
Eu pedi para metade de vocês olhar
para o lado verde da descrição,
que diz que o plano A é aquele em
que 200 pessoas vão viver,
enquanto que o plano B é aquele em
que há 1/3 de probabilidade
de 600 pessoas viverem e 2/3
de ninguém viver.
E a outra metade olhou
exatamente para o mesmo plano,
descrito não nos termos
de quem vai viver,
e sim de quem vai morrer.
Assim, o plano A diz: 200 das
600 pessoas vão viver,
o que significa a morte de 400.
E aqui o plano A significa que 400
das 600 pessoas morrem,
isto é, 200 seguem vivas.
No entanto, e esta foi o nosso
1º uso dos clickers,
as atitudes que vocês tiveram com os
casos diferem, ao passo que,
quando foi apresentado o número
de pessoas que viverão,
66% optaram pelo plano A e
apenas 34% escolheram o B.
Quando invertemos o enquadramento,
os números saíram exatamente o oposto.
Então, 66 de vocês favoreceram
o plano A no caso verde,
64 favoreceram o plano A no azul.
Mas o plano A e o plano B são
matematicamente idênticos.
Talvez isso seja o que está
acontecendo nos casos do trem.
E mesmo não sendo um exemplo real,
imaginem que vocês foram
apresentados ao seguinte:
Um trem está indo
desenfreado em direção
a 6 pessoas na sua cidade.
Você é o prefeito e tem 2
opções disponíveis:
o plano A e o plano B.
E então eu apresento o plano A para
você: 1 pessoa será salva,
o que significa que 5 pessoas morrem.
Ou o plano B: em que 1
pessoa vai morrer,
o que significa que 5
pessoas serão salvas.
E há uma inclinação, penso eu, para
ir com o plano B no caso azul
e o plano A no caso verde.
E isso é generalizado.
Dependendo em quem estamos
focando esses dilemas morais,
obtemos diferentes respostas.
Se pensarmos no caso do choro do
bebê de Josh Greene,
em que você está trancado num
porão com outras 19 pessoas
e o seu bebê chorando, cercados
por soldados inimigos
que matarão a todos se
forem encontrados,
o dilema é se você deve
asfixiar o bebê,
cujo choro vai chamar a atenção
para o esconderijo e causar a
morte de 20 pessoas?
Parece com o caso de Jim e os índios,
mas com uma premissa
ainda mais dolorosa.
Se você focar a sua
atenção nesse caso
para a experiência de
tapar a boca do bebê,
é praticamente impossível julgar isso
como a coisa moralmente obrigatória.
Mas se você redirecionar o foco
para a criança de 2 anos que
está ao lado, a de 4 anos,
o idoso no outro canto da sala...
todos eles vão morrer se você não
fizer nada com o bebê...
a sua resposta muda.
E a mudança no sentido da nossa
atenção é algo endêmico
em todos esses tipos de casos.
Nós somos capazes de nos
concentrarmos apenas
em partes do mundo ao mesmo tempo.
E, como resultado, é
incrivelmente difícil manter o
foco
de modo que esses tipos de dilemas
morais pareçam estáveis.
Portanto, Sunstein sugere que esse
fenômeno, pelo que ele caracteriza,
têm de ser moralmente
irrelevante... certo?
Ele não pode ser moralmente relevante
na coisa certa a se fazer
no caso do Trolley
se você enquadrá-lo segundo o
número de pessoas que vão viver
ou o número de mortes.
Pelo menos, prima facie,
isso não parece ser o tipo de coisa
que poderia ser relevante.
Você está tomando
exatamente a mesma decisão
enquadrada em 2 aspectos diferentes.
Como isso poderia ser o que
faz a diferença?
A sugestão de Sunstein é
que o mecanismo
que fundamenta o fenômeno que
eu acabei de descrever
ocorre repetidamente,
não apenas em casos hipotéticos no
estilo do problema do Trolley,
mas todo o tempo no tipo de
raciocínio moral
que nos envolvemos como
cidadãos de uma democracia,
tentando fazer julgamentos sobre a
distribuição de recursos,
sobre que tipos de leis devem
ser postas em prática
para regular ou incentivar certos
tipos de comportamento.
Assim, em cada um dos 4 domínios
seguintes, diz Sunstein,
nos concentramos muitas vezes nas
heurísticas, ou seja,
nas características da
superfície do fenômeno,
em vez dos atributos-alvo, isto é,
a coisa que nos preocupamos
numa última análise.
Lembrem-se que na última aula
eu falei sobre colocar uma
capa no celular
para que ele seja
facilmente identificável,
que isso dá acesso heurístico a
qual telefone é o seu.
Mas claro que esse adorno é útil
para encontrar o seu
celular apenas na medida
em que ele controla o atributo-alvo
que é importante para você,
ou seja, encontrar o telefone
que possui os contatos que são
importantes para você.
E quando alvos e
heurísticas se separam,
estamos em apuros.
Portanto, afirma Sunstein,
quando estamos pensando na
regulação do risco, isto é,
o que fazemos com o fato de
que, como seres humanos,
muitas coisas feitas tem o
potencial de causar dano,
mas nós não queremos passar as
nossas vidas envoltos em isopor,
movendo-nos muito lentamente pelo mundo,
para não se chocar com as coisas.
Considerando que estamos
dispostos a assumir riscos,
como é que a nossa tendência de
usar as heurísticas interage
com a nossa regulação?
Nos casos de punição, e
esse é o 1º tema
que vamos tratar depois da pausa,
Sunstein acha que usamos a
heurística de formas que nos levam
a nos comportarmos de
maneiras contraproducentes
ao punir os indivíduos e coletivos.
Em nossa hesitação para fazer
certos tipos de opções
na área da medicina
reprodutiva, pensa Sunstein,
corremos o risco de confundir as
heurísticas pelos alvos.
E tomando a distinção
ato-omissão tão a sério,
corremos o risco de confundir as
heurísticas pelos alvos.
Portanto, vamos voltar à questão
da punição logo após
o feriado e à questão do
ato-omissão na parte final da aula.
O que eu quero fazer agora é
verificar 3 exemplos
de regulação do risco a partir
da análise de Sunstein.
E a 3ª delas... Na verdade,
eu estou muito curiosa para ver os
números que vão sair daqui...
Portanto, Sunstein aponta, e
isso me parece correto,
que as pessoas são mais
suscetíveis a condenar uma empresa
quando o comportamento descrito
envolve a certeza de risco.
Portanto, eis a empresa A,
que oferece um produto usados por
10 milhões de pessoas,
que matará 10 pessoas.
Das 10 milhões de pessoas que
utilizam esse produto,
10 vão apresentar uma reação
que as levará à morte.
E o custo de eliminar totalmente esse
risco é de US$ 100 milhões.
Há uma sensação, uma
inclinação por parte de muitos,
em pensar que a empresa deve pagar
para se livrar desse risco;
que isso é inaceitável na
produção de um produto
em que 10 pessoas morrerão.
Em contrapartida, se enquadramos o caso
em termos de probabilidades,
que 10 milhões de pessoas
usam o produto,
que ele produz um risco de
morte de 1 por milhão
e eliminar o risco sai muito caro,
este é o tipo de coisa que nós
permitimos o tempo todo.
Sem esse tipo de tolerância ao risco não
haveria inovação tecnológica
e a maioria dos bens e recursos
que todos nós tomamos por certo
nunca teria existido.
Assim, a alegação de
Sunstein aqui é que,
embora os atributos-alvo sejam
idênticos nas 2 situações,
neste caso, 10 pessoas morrerão
e salvá-las teria um custo
de US$ 100 milhões.
Neste caso, 10 pessoas morrerão e
salvá-las teria um custo
de US$ 100 milhões; os
atributos-alvo são idênticos.
Em ambos os casos, 10 pessoas morrem
e salvá-las custa a
quantia especificada.
Os atributos heurísticos diferem.
Este está enquadrado em
termos de segurança;
este em termos de risco.
E nós temos uma ótima
heurística que é a seguinte:
Se 10 pessoas morrerão por causa
do que você está fazendo,
não faça isso.
E o argumento de Sunstein é que
a assimetria na resposta
para esses casos é irracional.
De fato, se propusermos
este caso a um risco
de 2 mortes por milhão
e tivermos este com uma
certeza de 10 mortes,
as pessoas ainda estariam inclinadas
a condenar a 1ª escolha,
embora, nessa conjuntura, a 2ª
opção seja claramente a pior.
Como resultado de interpretar mal os
atributos heurísticos pelos
de alvo, cometemos erros em que tipos
de comportamentos permitimos.
Sunstein acha que isso é o
que está acontecendo
no caso do comércio de
emissões ("cap and trade")
do qual ele foi um dos
primeiros defensores.
No modelo do comércio de emissões,
os poluidores recebem uma licença
para poluir "n" unidades de
poluição no ar e,
em seguida, negociam essas licenças
no mercado de tal forma que,
sem dúvida, diminui a
poluição a um custo menor.
Vamos deixar Sunstein com a economia...
Ainda assim, existe uma resistência
quanto ao "cap and trade".
Porque mesmo se estamos
dispostos a admitir
a presença do atributo-alvo
– isto é, que a quantidade de
poluição foi reduzida –,
o atributo heurístico...
"As pessoas estão pagando para poluir?
Você não deve estar habilitado a
pagar por um delito grave"...
nos parece problemático.
Agora, é um fenômeno interessante
que a resistência a esse tipo de
raciocínio ocorra segundo o contexto,
tanto da direita quanto da esquerda.
Portanto, há resistência à
mercantilização das coisas por parte
da esquerda e há resistência por
parte da direita a outros tipos
de enquadramentos que
sugerem que as respostas
em casos de tecnologias
reprodutivas como a clonagem são,
segundo Sunstein, devido à
heurística "não brinque de Deus".
E quando confrontados com a sugestão
"Você só está usando uma
heurística", ambos os lados
respondem com hostilidade à
análise acadêmica.
Nos anos 1970, era comum
os defensores do acúmulo de
arsenais nucleares
apelarem a uma noção chamada
"destruição mutuamente assegurada"
que falaremos quando falarmos do
dilema dos prisioneiros.
A ideia básica é que se ambos os
lados têm armas suficientes
para destruir o outro, então
nenhum vai utilizá-las,
porque a função de
dissuasão é muito grande.
Houve resistência por
parte da esquerda,
porque essa análise
parecia muito esperta.
Há resistência por ambos os
lados ao tipo de análise
exposto aqui por Sunstein, porque
ela vai contra a ideia
de que somos
introspectivamente
transparentes
de tal forma que os nossos
julgamentos são indicativos
das coisas que nos preocupamos.
Portanto, o último exemplo que
eu quero dar de Sunsteins
é a nossa enquete.
Sunstein formula... os seus
clickers estão funcionando?
Sunstein diz que nos sentimos
mais desconfortáveis
sendo prejudicados pelas coisas que
têm a função de nos proteger
que pelas coisas que não
têm essa função.
E ele sugere que existem dados mostrando
que se as pessoas podem
escolher entre 2 carros...
No 1º há uma chance de 2%
de você ser morto pelo volante,
caso se envolva num acidente.
E o 2º é um carro onde há
uma chance de 1%,
caso se envolva num acidente, de você
ser morto pelo volante, mas,
além disso, há um 1/10 de 1% de
chance do airbag matar você.
E a pergunta é: qual
carro você escolhe?
Aquele em que há uma chance de 2% de
você ser morto pelo volante
ou aquele em que há uma chance de 1% de
você ser morto pelo volante,
mas 1/10 de chance sobre 1% de
você ser morto pelo airbag,
que deveria protegê-lo.
E vamos ver os números que saem.
Eu tenho de dizer, estou
fazendo esta votação
porque as minhas intuições não
se alinham com Sunstein
e estou curiosa para saber a de vocês.
OK... Vamos ver como
saíram os números.
Assim, 15% de vocês
comprariam o carro A
e 85% de vocês comprariam o B.
Portanto, 85% estão fazendo
o que é a escolha
estatisticamente racional.
Mas uma boa parte de vocês está
disposta a arriscar um dano maior,
como para evitar este
sentimento de traição
por aquilo que tem a
função de proteger.
A sugestão de Sunstein, só para
resumir, é que no raciocínio moral
frequentemente substituímos os
atributos heurísticos
pelos alvos.
E isso é um erro.
Então, o que sugerem as 3
respostas ao problema do Trolley
consideradas por nós?
Bem, Thomson diz isto:
Que reconsiderar as nossas intuições a
partir de casos alternativos,
como é o caso
alternativo da
testemunha,
onde você imagina ser uma
das pessoas na via...
Que isso pode levar a mudanças
na nossa avaliação dos casos.
E essas mudanças nas nossas
respostas, ela pensa,
revelam algo moralmente significativo.
Podemos aprender com a
contemplação desses casos
específicos
o que a moralidade exige de nós.
Greene e Sunstein, por outro lado,
afirmam que a nossa intuição
responde a casos seguindo
frequentemente características que
são moralmente irrelevantes
e que, como consequência,
essas características não revelam
algo moralmente significativo.
A pergunta é esta:
Isso é um problema para Mill e Kant?
Vamos rever as páginas iniciais do
tratado de Mill sobre o utilitarismo.
Ele escreve lá... e eu não pedi
para ler esta passagem,
por isso não há nenhuma razão para
que vocês saibam o que ele diz.
"Embora na ciência
as verdades particulares
precedam a teoria geral,
pode-se esperar que aconteça o
contrário numa arte prática,
como a moral ou a legislação."
Portanto, na ciência,
analisamos casos particulares.
Descobrimos que soltamos este objeto e
ele cai com aceleração A,
soltamos este objeto e descobrimos que
soltamos este objeto e que ele
cai com aceleração A.
E, a partir daí, podemos concluir que a
lei que rege a queda dos corpos
é a que eles caem com aceleração A.
Portanto, "Embora na ciência
as verdades particulares
precedam a teoria geral,
pode-se esperar que aconteça o
contrário numa arte prática,
como a moral…
Um teste do certo e do errado tem
de ser o meio de determinar
aquilo que está certo e
aquilo que está errado…
e não uma consequência dos
termos já determinados".
"Não se consegue evitar a dificuldade
[de construir uma teoria de julgamentos]
recorrendo a" – o que às vezes é
chamado de senso moral –
"uma faculdade natural – diz
Mill – que discerne
aquilo que está certo e errado no caso
particular que enfrentamos",
assim como nossos outros sentidos
discernem a visão e o som presentes.
Portanto, como é possível ver se um
caso é moralmente errado.
O raciocínio moral, a
percepção moral, segundo ele,
"é um ramo da nossa razão, não da
nossa faculdade sensível".
A moralidade da ação individual…
é uma questão da aplicação da
lei a um caso particular…
Assim sendo, qualquer que seja a
firmeza ou constância
que a nossa crença moral
tenha alcançado,
é devido à influência tácita dessa
norma reflexivamente disponível.
Mill está construindo a teoria de
teorias, e não a teoria de casos.
Kant. "Não se poderia prestar
pior serviço à moralidade
do que querer extraí-la de exemplos.
Pois cada exemplo [...] tem de
ser primeiro julgado
segundo os princípios da
moralidade para se saber
se é digno de servir de exemplo
original, isto é, de modelo."
Temos aqui, de certa forma,
corporificado, o diálogo deste curso.
Até que ponto a nossa
capacidade de reflexão racional
é o melhor caminho para responder às
perguntas que nos preocupam?
Até que ponto a nossa capacidade
para a resposta emocional,
para a sensação, para o
julgamento instintivo
com base na apresentação de
casos particulares
é um indicativo das respostas às
questões que nos preocupam?
Portanto, isso fecha a
discussão dos casos do Trolley.
E o que eu quero fazer na
2ª metade da aula
é percorrer 2 tipos de quebra-cabeças
que persistem independentemente
de qual atitude tomamos.
O 1º é algo apresentado a vocês
como nota promissória na 1ª aula
expositiva, porque este é
um dos trabalhos mais
divertidos que leremos.
É o artigo de Roy Sorensen com
[Christopher] Boorse
sobre esquiva e sacrifício.
Vocês se lembram, esse
foi o fim de semana
que o senador do Arizona foi baleado,
então eu não podia fazer
isso com balas.
Vocês se lembrem do caso...
você está numa fila.
Você é o cara amarelo.
E um urso está vindo na sua direção.
E se você sair da fila,
o urso come a pessoa atrás de você.
Contraste isso com o caso em que
você está numa fila.
Você ainda é o cara amarelo.
Um urso está vindo na sua direção
e você se vira, pega o
cara atrás de você
e o coloca na sua frente; e
o urso come ele.
O 1º é um caso clássico
chamado de esquiva.
Ou seja, você está numa situação
em que há um mal vindo
na sua direção.
Você sai do caminho do mal
e o mal atinge outra
pessoa no seu lugar.
O 2º é um caso clássico
de sacrifício.
Há um mal vindo na sua direção
e você utiliza outra
pessoa como escudo.
Então, esquivar-se é evitar danos,
permitindo que ele recaia
em outra pessoa.
Sacrificar é evitar danos
provocando que o mal vá para outro,
se você usar essa pessoa como escudo.
E isso é análogo à
distinção ato-omissão,
já vista por nós,
mas está totalmente dentro
do reino das ações.
Agora, o que Sorensen e
Boorse trazem no artigo
é o quão resiliente é este
fenômeno, independentemente
de como você embaralha o
enquadramento dos casos.
Eles dão o exemplo do
atirador no shopping.
Há uma bala vindo na sua direção
e a sua opção é pular para o lado
ou puxar alguém para a sua frente,
evitando que a bala acerte você.
É o caso do caminhão em
alta velocidade.
Você está numa fila de carros.
Um caminhão vem em alta
velocidade atrás de você;
ele vai bater no seu carro.
E você tem 2 coisas a fazer.
Na 1ª, você muda de pista
e o caminhão bate no carro que
estava na sua frente.
Na 2ª, você indica para um carro
que está atrás de você
que ele mude para a sua pista...
e o caminhão bate nele.
Há o caso dos terroristas.
Você está num avião.
Uns terroristas líbios
– boa hora para falar
sobre a Líbia –,
neste exemplo, tomam o seu avião
e ameaçam matar todos os
norte-americanos.
Você é um representante
do Departamento de Estado dos EUA
e a sua pasta tem um adesivo
da instituição,
e os terroristas estão vindo no
corredor, prestes a atirar em você.
2 possibilidades.
Você cobre o adesivo com etiqueta
da companhia aérea líbia,
então eles vão saltar você e atirar
na mulher sentada ao seu lado,
a próximo da fila.
Ou você troca a sua pasta com a
da pessoa ao seu lado e,
portanto, eles vão matá-la em
vez de atirar em você.
Ou o caso dos barcos afundando.
Você está em alto mar.
Você está tentando sinalizar que o
seu barco está afundando,
o barco do cara ao lado está afundando.
Você está tentando avisar
um avião que sobrevoa vocês.
E você pode fazer 1 de 2 coisas:
Você pode aumentar o seu sinal, certo?
Fazer uma luz muito forte e, em
seguida, o avião vai resgatá-lo.
Ou você pode bloquear o
sinal do outro cara,
sinalizando relativamente mais forte
para que a companhia aérea
venha resgatar você.
Sorensen fornece vários
casos sobre o tema.
Se insetos estão comendo as suas rosas,
está bem colocar
repelente nas suas rosas,
o que fará com eles migrem
para o jardim do vizinho;
mas não está bem colocar atrativo
de insetos nas rosas dele.
Temos essa estranha tendência de pensar
que está bem esquivar-se
mas não blindar-se.
Agora, a perplexidade que
Sorensen e Boorse consideram
é que parece que não há
nenhuma maneira sistemática
para explicar esses tipos de
discrepâncias na intuição.
Vocês podem pensar o seguinte:
O problema nesses casos é que,
quando você amarra os pés
do seu oponente,
quando você está
tentando fugir do urso,
ou quando você o empurra
no caso do disparo,
você interfere na concorrência leal.
E essa concorrência leal é o que
importa nesse tipo de circunstâncias.
Mas, claro, há um monte
de circunstâncias
em que a competição é
injusta já de início.
E, no entanto, isso ainda
parece problemático.
Mesmo que o cara que você esteja
tentando "oferecer" ao urso
seja um corredor muito mais
lento que você,
ainda não parece bem
amarrar os sapatos dele.
A justiça da competição
não parece ser
o que está conduzindo a intuição.
Por isso, talvez, eles digam que em
cada um dos casos de "empurrão"
o que você faz é, de alguma
forma, o errado contido.
É errado pegar alguém e
colocar na sua frente.
Ao passo que, está tudo bem se
abaixar para que algo o atinja.
É errado roubar a pasta de alguém.
É errado bloquear o sinal de alguém.
Mas, eles ressaltam, parece tão ruim
colocar a pessoa na sua frente de
forma amigável, dizendo
"Você gostaria de ver uma bela vista?"
como agarrá-la e
colocá-la na sua frente.
Segundo eles, é tão
problemático forçar alguém
a pular de um penhasco gritando "E=MC2!"
como é induzi-la a saltar do penhasco
gritando um epíteto racial.
O errado contido não parece ser o
que explica a nossa resposta.
Por isso, eu vou deixar vocês
lerem estas respostas
se vocês ainda não tiveram a chance...
No entanto, a distinção ato-omissão
ou a distinção feito-permitido
não parece suficiente para
realizar o trabalho.
Tampouco a ideia de que o que importa
é se você fosse o locus de
uma cadeia causal,
o criador de uma
sequência de causalidade.
Tampouco a doutrina do efeito duplo
parece dar conta de todos esses casos.
Tampouco recorrer à noção
de direitos de Kant
em contraste com os utilitários
parece explicar todos esses casos.
Sorensen e Boorse, um pouco relutantes,
consideram uma conclusão de ceticismo.
Que, basicamente, é que isso é uma
característica hesitante
da nossa psicologia.
Mas nós, ao ter ouvido a
1ª metade da aula,
temos outra explicação alternativa.
E eu não prometo que
funcionará em todos os casos,
embora pareça bastante promissora.
O que está ocorrendo nos casos
de esquiva e blindagem
é a sobreaplicação de
uma heurística.
Em geral, parece que sair do
caminho de um dano
não é uma coisa ruim a se fazer,
enquanto que colocar alguém
no caminho de um dano
é algo ruim a se fazer.
Portanto, talvez esse 1º
conjunto de quebra-cabeças
possa ser explicado por meio
das heurísticas.
Eu quero focar os últimos
15 minutos da aula
num conjunto de quebra-cabeças.
E para isso, vocês vão
precisar dos seus clickers.
Portanto, vamos começar
com 4 motoristas.
O 1º deles, o Alberto Sortudo,
faz o seguinte:
Ele entra no seu carro.
O seu carro está em
perfeitas condições.
Ele está atento a cada semáforo.
Ele dirige de uma forma
extremamente segura.
E, no final do dia, chega em
casa do trabalho.
É isso aí. Este é o Alberto Sortudo.
Questão: Quando o Alberto Sortudo
dirige até a casa dele,
deixando de lado se a amante
também está no carro,
se ele comprou um carro
que possui uma alta taxa de emissões
em vez de comprar um Prius...
Enquanto ele dirige, deixando de lado
todas as outras coisas moralmente
erradas que possa ter feito,
será que ele fez algo
moralmente condenável
ao dirigir do trabalho para casa, tendo
o seu carro perfeitamente bem,
sem fazer mal a ninguém
durante o caminho?
Essa não é uma pergunta capciosa.
Portanto, se você acha o
Alberto Sortudo
fez algo moralmente condenável,
deixando de lado todas as coisas
que são moralmente condenáveis
alheias à condução, aperte 1.
E se você acha que ele não fez
nada moralmente condenável,
aperte 2.
Então o que vocês estão julgando é:
é moralmente problemático
dirigir do trabalho para casa
– considerando todas as coisas,
se nada de ruim acontece?
E vamos esperar que... OK.
Portanto, há sempre estes 5%.
As multidões anticarro.
São os mesmos que fazem Medicina
para fatiar o pobre rapaz
saudável da sala de espera.
95% de vocês pensam que o
Alberto Sortudo
não fez nada moralmente condenável.
Vamos conhecer o irmão gêmeo do
Alberto Sortudo: o Alberto Azarado.
Aqui está o que o Alberto Azarado fez:
Exatamente o mesmo que o
Alberto Sortudo.
Exceto que quando ele chegava em casa,
uma criança saltou na frente do
seu carro e ele a atingiu.
OK? O Alberto Azarado
fez exatamente o mesmo que o Sortudo.
Saiu do trabalho, checou os pneus,
esteve atento o tempo todo,
dirigiu a uma velocidade
segura e adequada.
Mas, por azar, no caminho de
casa matou uma criança.
Questão: Será que o Alberto Azarado
faz algo moralmente condenável?
Para sim, pressione 1.
Para não, pressione 2.
E eu vou anotar aqui os números do
primeiro caso... 5 e 95.
OK. Então vamos ver os
números que saem desta vez.
Aqui, 81% de vocês acham que ele não
fez algo moralmente condenável,
mas estamos acima de 5%...
19% de pessoas pensam que ele fez
algo moralmente condenável.
Vamos ao nosso 3º caso.
Aqui está o sr. Celular Sortudo.
Aqui está o feito do sr.
Celular Sortudo.
Ele entra no carro e começa a
dirigir do trabalho para casa.
E, durante o trajeto, ele fala
ao telefone celular...
Mas sabem o quê? Não acontece nada.
E ele chega em casa sem
prejudicar ninguém.
Questão: Será que o Celular Sortudo
faz algo moralmente condenável
na condução do trabalho para
casa falando ao celular?
E vamos ver como estes números saem.
OK. O veredicto de vocês é:
78% acha que o Celular Sortudo
fez alguma coisa...
gente, eu não acredito nisso.
Quero dizer, vocês estão se
antecipando ao próximo caso!
Todos vocês usam o celular
enquanto dirigem
e vocês não pensam em vocês mesmos
como fazendo algo
moralmente condenável!
OK. Estes dados não são válidos.
Isso tem a ver com o lugar onde eles
estão inseridos neste experimento.
Tudo bem.
Portanto, mesmo que vocês já
tenham respondido à pergunta 4,
deixa eu fazê-la.
O Celular Azarado vai do
trabalho para casa
falando ao telefone celular.
Uma criança salta na frente
do carro dele e...
OK. Questão.
Durante o trajeto até a
casa, o Celular Azarado
faz algo moralmente condenável?
E vamos ver os números que saem.
Tudo bem.
Vamos ver onde aparece a grande linha
vermelha do Celular Azarado.
OK. Agora temos uma mudança
completa da original
e, de fato, diferente do
nosso caso anterior.
OK. Portanto, o que esses
exemplos demonstram
é um fenômeno conhecido
como a sorte moral.
Temos 2 pessoas aqui, o Alberto
Sortudo e o Alberto Azarado,
que fazem exatamente a mesma coisa,
mas as ações do Azarado
causaram a morte de um inocente.
E enquanto apenas 5% de vocês pensam
que o Alberto Sortudo fez algo errado,
19% acham que o Alberto
Azarado fez algo errado.
Temos aqui, de forma similar,
alguém que assumiu um risco ligeiro,
que neste caso não teve
consequências ruins
e, neste caso, teve
consequências ruins muito
graves.
E 92% de vocês condenaram
o Celular Azarado.
O fenômeno que ilustra isso é
conhecido como a sorte moral.
Casos em que a culpa moral de uma
ação ou de suas consequências
é atribuída a um agente,
mesmo que o agente não
tenha controle total
sobre tal ação ou suas consequências.
Certo? Não é que o Alberto
Azarado ou o Celular Azarado
queria que a criança saltasse
na frente do carro.
Não é que o Alberto Azarado
ou o Celular Azarado
pudesse fazer algo diferente
naquele instante.
A criança estava na frente do carro e
o carro atingiu a criança.
A sorte moral é desconcertante,
porque parece que temos 2
compromissos concorrentes
quando pensamos sobre a
responsabilidade moral.
Por um lado, parece que
estamos aceitando algo
que poderíamos chamar de
princípio do controle:
que louvor e culpa morais não
devem ser atribuídos em casos
em que a ação ou as consequências
estão além do controle do agente.
E eu vejo que muitos de vocês
aderiram ao princípio de controle,
porque 81% acharam que o
motorista azarado
não fez nada moralmente errado,
mesmo ao ter matado uma criança.
E o motivo para que vocês
estejam inclinados a pensar
que ele não fez nada
errado, eu suspeito,
é porque o julgamento nesse
caso, como disse Mill,
está regulado por um princípio
aderido tacitamente por vocês.
Ou seja, algo como o
princípio do controle.
É intuitivamente plausível, diz Nagel,
que as pessoas não possam ser
moralmente avaliadas
por aquilo que não é culpa delas
ou devido a fatores fora
do controle delas.
Se você esbarrar em mim,
eu tropeçar e acidentalmente cair
no botão vermelho que faz
com que comece uma guerra
nuclear, não é culpa minha.
É uma coisa terrivelmente ruim que
o planeta seja destruído,
mas eu só tropecei.
Por outro lado, em oposição direta
ao princípio do controle e segundo
atesta o princípio da sorte moral,
parece que em alguns casos
devem ser atribuídos
louvor e culpa morais,
mesmo quando a ação ou
as consequências
estão além do controle do agente.
A diferença nas respostas
entre os casos dos
sortudos e dos azarados
indicam o grau em que
vocês aderiram a isso.
Portanto, vocês foram de 95% a
81% de não culpabilidade.
Vocês mudaram... 15%
mudaram de opinião
como consequência de algo fora
do controle do agente.
No caso do celular,
de novo, cerca de 15% de vocês
mudaram de opinião.
O problema é que esses 2 princípios
são incrivelmente
difíceis de desprezar.
O princípio do controle se baseia no
seguinte tipo de raciocínio:
Em geral, temos um bom senso
de que tipo de fatores
aumentam o merecimento ou a
culpabilidade de uma ação.
Em geral, se um ato é voluntário,
ou seja, se você faz isso
não por coerção ou por
engano... certo?
Se você escolheu executar a
ação executada...
então você recebe mais
elogios por tê-la executado
se era uma boa ação
e mais culpa se era uma má ação.
Do mesmo jeito, se você tivesse
a informação completa,
se estivesse ciente das
prováveis ??consequências,
sabendo que era água ou cianeto o que
você deu para a pessoa beber,
isso aumenta o grau de
merecimento ou culpabilidade.
E essas são respostas bastante robustas
que incidem não apenas na
análise dos casos,
mas também fora da nossa
compreensão dos princípios
que parecem fundamentar a
responsabilidade moral.
Do mesmo modo, parece que a
ausência dessas características
diminui o merecimento ou a
culpabilidade moral.
Se você fizer algo sob coação, se você
fizer alguma coisa acidentalmente,
a sua responsabilidade é menor.
E se você fizer alguma coisa por
falta de informação, se eu,
pensando que eu estou dando algo
saudável para você,
acabar dando algo prejudicial,
temos uma tendência a mitigar o
grau de culpabilidade.
O princípio do controle diz que,
sem uma diferença nesses fatores,
como é possível ter uma diferença
entre merecimento e culpabilidade?
Se mantivermos esses fatores constantes,
devemos estar numa situação
onde não existe diferença na
responsabilidade moral.
Por outro lado, o princípio da sorte
moral também é muito forte.
Parece inegável que haja
casos em que avaliamos
o louvor e a culpa morais na
ausência de controle.
O caso do motorista foi um deles.
Um dos usuários do celular atinge
a criança; o outro não.
O 1º é moralmente condenável.
Eu deixo o fogão aceso na minha
casa... ou na sua casa.
Eu vou visitar você e deixo o
fogão aceso na sua casa.
Eu saio durante o dia.
Se eu sou azarada, isso causa um
incêndio na sua casa.
Se eu tiver sorte, isso não ocorre.
Parece que, mesmo achando que
ambas coisas são ruins,
é muito pior deixar o fogão
aceso e queimar a casa
que deixar o fogão aceso, simplesmente.
Nagel dá o exemplo de deixar
um bebê na banheira
e sair um momento.
É uma coisa irresponsável, mas
infinitamente mais problemática
se o bebê se afogar.
Ou o caso em que você e eu
temos caráteres parecidos.
Eu fico na Alemanha; você não.
Estamos na década de 1930. Eu
me torno um nazista;
você vive a sua vida sem que haja
exigências morais para você.
Portanto, há 3 tipos de
respostas que podemos dar
aos casos de sorte moral.
Podemos dar uma resposta racionalista.
Podemos dizer:
a sorte não pode desempenhar um
papel na avaliação moral.
E podemos ir ao outro extremo, pensando
– tal como um kantiano puro
– que todo agente é
responsável pela sua vontade
e pelas coisas às quais ele
tem controle total.
Ou podemos aceitar algo como uma
versão extrema de Mill.
Que o agente é responsável por
todas as consequências
de suas ações e que a atitude
não faz diferença.
Você pode tomar uma atitude
irracionalista nesse sentido.
Você pode dizer
que a sorte pode desempenhar algum
papel na avaliação moral.
Ou, ainda que isso seja muito
difícil de sustentar,
você pode dizer que nunca sabemos a
responsabilidade de alguém
numa ação até vermos quais são
as consequências dela.
Que quando eu fundamentava que
esses casos eram idênticos,
eu estava idealizando de
forma ilegítima.
Parece que a 3ª resposta pode funcionar
nos casos clássicos de sorte
moral descritos por mim,
casos que poderíamos chamar
de sorte resultante,
onde há sorte no resultado da ação.
Eu executo uma ação e ela sai errado de
uma maneira que eu não esperava.
Essa é uma categoria de
casos de sorte moral.
Mas é mais difícil de ver como
podemos usar essa explicação
em algumas instâncias profundas.
Portanto, aceitem a sorte constitutiva.
Alguns de vocês nasceram com genes
que faz com que seja mais fácil se
comportar de maneira altruísta;
e alguns de vocês não.
Alguns de vocês foram
criados em famílias
que favoreceram determinados tipos
de perspectivas morais;
e alguns de vocês não.
Será que o seu caráter resulta
dessas características
sobre algo que você é responsável;
e se não, como é que algo
relacionado com louvor e culpa moral
pode ser avaliado?
Aceitem a sorte circunstancial,
que Jonathan Shay apresentou em
Achilles in Vietnam –
a sorte no tocante ao entorno do agente.
Às vezes, as circunstâncias
em que você está
criam ou revelam características
ocultas do seu caráter.
Isso significa que – já que elas são,
em parte, uma questão de sorte –
você não é moralmente
responsável pelo que você fez?
Finalmente, se começarmos a
pensar em nossas ações
pela perspectiva do livre-arbítrio, é
difícil trinchar qualquer espaço
em que nós somos responsáveis
??por aquilo que fazemos.
É um fato geral sobre o mundo que as
ações e as consequências
são, em geral, determinadas em parte
pelas características externas ou,
pelo menos, fora do controle do agente.
Então, se pensarmos por que é
que respondemos dessa forma
ao caso do Trolley, veremos que é
porque a parte emocional do
nosso cérebro está acesa.
Mas por que isso está acontecendo?
Bem, isso está acontecendo por
causa do fluxo de sangue,
acontecendo em nosso cérebro.
E por que isso está acontecendo?
Bem, o sangue está
fluindo nessa direção
por causa de certos tipos de moléculas.
E ao pensar sobre isso, a área
da agência genuína,
diz Nagel, parece encolher a um
ponto sem extensão.
Então, antes da pausa de março,
deixo vocês com a seguinte
não-solução intrigante
de um problema moral muito profundo.
Nagel sugere que o problema da
sorte não tem solução
porque algo na ideia de perceber a
nós mesmos como agentes
é incompatível com o fato inegável
de que as ações são eventos
e as pessoas são coisas.
"Como os determinantes externos
do que alguém fez estão
gradualmente expostos no seu
efeito nas consequências,
caráter e escolha própria, torna-se
gradualmente claro para nós
que as ações são, de fato, eventos
e que as pessoas são coisas.
Como resultado disso,
não resta nada que possa ser
atribuído ao próprio responsável,
e não nos sobra nada além de uma
porção da maior sequência
de eventos que pode ser
lamentada ou celebrada,
mas não louvada ou culpada."
No entanto, abandonar a
linguagem de louvor e culpa
é retirar do nosso
repertório conceitual
o que talvez seja a ferramenta
mais importante que temos.
E chegar a uma perspectiva
estável sobre essas questões
parece extremamente difícil.
Portanto, eu vejo todos
vocês após o feriado.